welcome to their famous Friday I believe
that whatever goal you have the fastest
way to accomplish it is to model success
find someone who's already done what
you're trying to do learn from them and
apply their strategies to your business
to also achieve similar success so
today's lesson is from body shop founder
Anita Roddick and it's get past survival
and neither onyx parents wanted her to
be a teacher and she was on that path to
become a teacher and and she felt like
this wasn't for her she had to do
something different she had to be her
own creative person and so she left the
teaching business to travel the world
she learned about different cultures she
learned the real different people and
she took all those experiences about how
the world works and brought it back to
England there she met Gordon Roddick who
she felt was a kindred spirit they
married they had two girls and they
started their own bed-and-breakfast
hotel and then life took a huge turn for
them in 1976 Gordon Roddick decided that
he wanted to fulfill his lifelong dream
of riding a horse from Buenos Aires
Argentina to New York City and to
finance it he'd have to sell the
business and leave Anita and the two
girls there until the following year now
most of us would say what are you crazy
you're gonna leave me alone without any
income without any business with the two
girls while you're off traveling until
next year to ride a horse from Buenos
Aires to New York City are you nuts
but instead Anita's response was it
blissed me out to have a partner who
said I've got to do this I've got to be
remarkable so she agreed and he left and
now she had to start a business as her
only way to make an income to provide
for herself and who two girls while her
husband was away that's why she started
the body shop and I'll let her tell it
in her own words it really came about as
a livelihood I needed to have a
livelihood to look after my two kids
when my husband went 14 years riding a
horse across South America
and we were it was so it was just a
woman are very good at having mixing
what they're interested in and what
they're talented at and making some sort
of livelihood from it so I was a teacher
I had worked for the United Nations
International Labour office I traveled
and that was really for me wherever I
traveled I was usually in in arenas not
of Western type civilization but in
areas where indigenous people were so I
lived a lot of the time in western
Africa South Africa a lot of the Indian
Ocean islands Pacific Ocean islands and
everywhere I traveled I lived in fishing
communities and I picked up the rituals
of the body
women had good it that many lives in it
but women world famous birth marriages
and death or what do you bring your body
then oh don't you put yogurt there so
those became like it was like a sort of
a closet on anthropologists when I came
back from the Travers and ten years
later in my early 30s I decided to open
up this little shop and it is only going
to tread water for two years and then
we're going off to I think Australia to
open up a pineapple plantation got the
money four thousand pounds for the
miserable Barclays bank manager who
didn't give it to me actually because my
father because I was wearing a Bob Dylan
t-shirt and jeans I have my two kids
destroying his office but bank managers
don't like enthusiastic I was going I've
got this great idea and it's gonna be
called the body shop and I all these and
all these knowledgeable ingredients from
wise women around the world well the guy
I think thought I was going to open up
Brighton's first sex shop or something
so he didn't give me the money so Gordon
my husband came back with me and I
looked like a man so I wore my pinstripe
suit and we had a plastic sheet we've
just come into you know plastic folder
had a profit and loss thing which we
didn't even know what we were doing and
he gave Gordon the four thousand pounds
not me Gordon hand me the money and he
went off to do his trip and I opened up
this little shop in Brighton first day I
was in trouble because I had my shop was
between two funeral parlors and they
didn't like the coffins passing my shop
with the words of body shop over the
side so they told me to close the name
down to close
change the name the bodyshop which I
couldn't do because I just spent seven
hundred pounds you know doing goldleaf
lettering and nobody could see anyway I
think did something very small I did an
anima spell call to the local newspapers
so I'm being intimidated by mafia
Undertaker's and my husband had just
deserted me so I mean I've got I knew
how to talk to people so we started I
started that twenty five products in
uselessness about as big as a table were
sitting on so what I did was and this is
this is what entrepreneurial thinking is
about I did five sizes of everything so
it looked like in over a hundred like
smart a handwritten labels not so smart
but we were the writing ran in the
bathroom everybody did it and so we
survived but we had stories every
product had a story how I made it what
mistake I made don't worry about the
black bits oh the dirty footprints of
the bees just scoop it out you know
lovely anecdotes and it dose adhere to
the mind Gordon came back I'd opened up
a second shop and he sort of said this
is interesting so he we came up this
idea self on it we didn't even know the
word franchising exists so for Anita
Roddick who was all about survival he
was one of my favorite quotes from her
nobody talks of entrepreneurship as
survival but that's exactly what it is
and what nurtures creative thinking so
it's great to have that big goal that
big dream that big desire to want to
change the world that's what gets you
excited and motivated they get up every
day and go to work but don't get so
fixated on that big picture that you
forget the little steps your step one is
getting past survival you have to get to
the point where you can put food on the
table and pay your mortgage and pay your
electricity and phone bills because if
you can't do that then there's no way
you're gonna hit that big goal of yours
so always keep that big dream of yours
in the back of your mind and let it
motivate you but remember that the first
steps of entrepreneurship are about
survive believe I love to hear your
survival stories your challenges your
questions if you want to leave a comment
below I'm going to be joining in that
discussion and if you like this video
you want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much for watching I'll see you soon
I'm Calvin Murray I'm a
singer-songwriter and regular
personality I subscribe to Eva's
newsletter a few years ago it has really
helped me the newsletter is very
informative and inspiring and it has
helped me throughout my career so I
encourage you to don't give up you can
make it subscribe to Evans newsletter
today you won't regret it
you